plus de 50 ans que nous ne sommes pas
allés sur la lune les dernières missions
n'étaient même plus télédiffées il y
avait un désintérêt total complètement
alors pourquoi on y retourne là alors
vous allez nous expliquer Artemis 2 en
novembre 2024 va faire il part de la
Floride oui c'est quelque tours de la
terre pour faire deux et se propulse
pour quitter la gravité de la terre en
fait et ensuite il s'insère dans
l'orbite dans la gravité de la lune donc
à partir de ce moment là ils vont
ressentir la gravité de la Lune et de
moins en moins ressentir la gravité de
la terre passer derrière la lune se
rapprocher environ 7000 km de la surface
de la Lune puis revenir vers la terre
d'un seul coup ça prend quand même du
temps ça prend digital 10 jours à peu
près parce que saint Jacques lui quand
on va dans la station orbitale on est
tout près là on est ici juste à la
surface de la Terre à 400 km d'altitude
là on est rendu ici à 400 000 km
environ 1000 fois plus c'est énorme donc
au total ils feront un million de
kilomètres dans cette fusée qui est un
engin assez grand assez spacieux assez
confortable c'est la capsule Orient qui
peut accueillir 4 astronautes alors
pourquoi on fait ça
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que il y a un contexte géopolitique avec
la Chine faut pas l'oublier la Chine a
décidé d'aller sur la Lune et de poser
une femme sur la lune une taille
qu'onôte on appelle ça une astronaute
chinoise dans au courant des années
25-26 donc les Américains ont aussi
désiré concurrencer la Chine donc ça
c'est le premier argument géopolitique
qui justifie l'investissement qui est
colossal on parle de 110 milliards de
dollars le programme Artemis c'est
énorme mais pourquoi que faire le
pourquoi on allunit pas pourquoi on ne
se dépose pas sur la Lune qu'on ne fait
que le tout pour Artemis 2 simplement en
fait parce que c'est compliqué et on
veut pas se rater on veut être sûr que
les astronautes arrivent en sécurité
lors de Artémis 3 donc on prend toutes
les précautions nécessaires on fait un
Artemis 1 sans astronaute sans équipage
à un Artémis 2 avec astronaute
exactement comme dans la mission Apollo
avec Apollo 8 et ensuite Artémis 3 2025
c'est ça 2025 2D catastrophes vont
descendre des marchés donc une femme une
personne de couleur bon question naïve
on l'a fait ça on était sur la lune on a
marché qu'est-ce qu'on va apprendre de
plus pourquoi je vous repose la même
question alors on le fait pas de la même
façon on a ce qu'on appelle le Lunar
Gateway qui va être construit
probablement qui sera pas encore tout à
fait prêt pour Artemis 3 donc ce sera
pour les prochaines missions Artemis
mais ce Lunar Gateway on veut s'en
servir pour pouvoir l'utiliser pour
aller vers d'autres planètes et c'est
une façon et facile en fait d'économiser
de l'énergie et de construire un
vaisseau spatial beaucoup plus gros et
beaucoup plus pratique pour aller vers
une planète vers Mars mais pour pouvoir
aller vers Mars pour limiter les risques
on choisit d'abord d'aller sur la lune
de retourner sur la Lune pour pouvoir y
arriver on va voir le système solaire et
parce que l'objectif vous venez de le
dire c'est d'aller sur Mars
éventuellement quand on le sait pas ça
alors terre Lune Mars là c'est encore
plus loin ah oui
une
maison
en face de lancement comme dans les
films de science-fiction on crée sa base
de lancement autour de la Lune c'est pas
tellement plus près quand même c'est pas
tellement plus près mais par contre
l'avantage c'est que pendant qu'on
prépare des astronautes et qu'on
construit des fusées qui vont aller de
la lune vers Mars on peut construire
autour de la Lune tout le nécessaire
pour avoir des ravitaillements pour
avoir un vaisseau spatial beaucoup plus
grand qu'on aurait du mal à faire partir
de la terre parce qu'il serait beaucoup
trop lourd alors on utilise la faible
gravité de la lune pour pouvoir le faire
partir plus simplement plus facilement
avec moins de carburant bon je jamais
Artémis 2 donc
en tournant autour de la Lune est-ce que
nos moyens technologiques étant plus
avancés que ceux d'Apollo est-ce qu'on
va prendre des photos ou des mesures qui
vont nous apprendre quelque chose sur la
lune ou on sait tout de la lune des gens
on sait pas beaucoup de choses de la
lune on a ramené quelques centaines de
kilos de roches lunaires au cours des
missions Apollo mais on en a besoin de
plus pour connaître la géologie de la
lune donc on va en ramener avec le
programme Artemis on a besoin aussi de
creuser dans la lune de comprendre sa
composition cette fois-ci parce qu'on
dépose aussi mais il faut préparer
toutes ces étapes là pour pouvoir
déposer en fait le matériel nécessaire
pour le faire plus tard donc en 2024 en
novembre c'est vraiment on regarde si
l'autobus fonctionne exactement
on y va on vient déjà ça va être
beaucoup là ça va être beaucoup on veut
que ça ce qu'on le fasse en sécurité
très bien monsieur un indice merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé on va on va
suivre ça bien sûr